- [Voiceover] This is Ping,
a southern three-banded armadillo.
Predators, look elsewhere.
You'll have a hard time
cracking open this critter.
Like all armadillos, they
are covered by bony plates
that make up their shell.
But the southern three-banded armadillo
is the only armadillo species
that can roll themselves
into a near-perfect ball when threatened.
These little guys are native
to central South America
and prefer dry vegetation.
There, they feed off insects
that they dig up with their
sharp, powerful claws,
and gather with long,
sticky, straw-like tongue.
But even body armor can't
protect this species
from numerous human-made threats.
On top of a dwindling habitat,
they are hunted heavily
for food and the pet trade.
This is the southern
three-banded armadillo.